back
[Music]
way back
[Music]
maverick here
preparing to pursue target
talk to me quarterback goose
roger that quarterback goose here
you give him hell i got your six
okay
i have target locked
we see this as a violent threat
you bet your sweet ass jack dorsey
engaging target roger that maverick
[Music]
damn it
missed him
uh maverick looks like you have company
on your tail where did zuckerberg get
here as long as there are people
spreading misinformation this is going
to be an ongoing conflict well this
complicates things
seems like my invite got lost in the
mail two cute man
tell him to put the zima on ice now the
party started
i got a call and some boys were trying
to do a woman's job
yeah yeah i've heard it all before let
me show you boys how a real lady does
too cute maddie oh my god oh my
god oh my god
[Music]
uh hell looks like you have a widget on
your five
we have community guidelines anything
that promotes hate we will take it down
this day just keeps getting better and
better
wouldn't be so sure
i can't shake her
oh shoot she's locked onto me
[Music]
i hear you boys ordered a half asian ass
kicking half asian lawyer bill
richardson half asian lawyer bill
richman you son of a [ __ ] don't worry
boys i got this
that's what i'm talking about looks like
you just got sucker burned
[ __ ] go get some
hey jack you know the difference between
precedent and precedence i don't have
answers to that because i'm about to set
one
right on your ass
[Applause]
he got all of that one
[Music]
oh hey susan you ordered no msg right
yeah i hear it's bad for your help you
know what's worse me
don't worry boys
looks like i'm gonna have to do this the
old fashioned water bill now
[Music]
oh my god
oh my god
half asian lawyer bill richardson talk
to me
[Music]
do you read me half asian lawyer
pilgrimage
you boys didn't think you could get rid
of me that easy did you fish and bill
you're alive
yeah we thought you were a gunner half
asian phil and miss all those billable
hours not a chance
i'm just glad you're okay
just checked your lady longo
looks like you'll be landing in palo
alto before beer clock hello alto
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
stranger
speedy
[Music]
that's like uh uh the donald trump
drinking the cup of water because uh
i think i broke my forearm uh falling
down the stairs
the stair technically no that actually
yes the stair stinky singular
it was the last step yeah fred yes
man makes me very comfortable yes he is
fleet of foot no i just uh i i
dislocated my ankle which is bad and i
put a pop back in going down the stairs
and then i fell and i hit my form and i
was the good thing is i was alone at
night because i actually went
we have video so yeah just like that
like a little lady and then i woke up
this morning and i haven't been able to
close my i don't know could that be a
fracture could it be a bone bruise i
don't know lewis just shook his head
yeah he actually did because he's it's
dark in the house but she's just like a
ghost so i just see a head pop up from
the couch
he didn't care you can still feed me
okay didn't care
like a new valdez police officer oh
this is going to be a rough show so i
just left because i agree yes i agree
too hey this is why you don't just
blindly back the blue we've caught flack
for that in the past this is also why
you don't hey
you know let me ask this is a question
of the day before we move on to anything
else um
do you want to defund the police or
disarm citizens
comment below because he can't have both
we want those guys the validity police
officers be the only ones with guns by
the way i vote neither neither i vote
better equipping of the police better
training more so they had the equipment
they just didn't have the training and
uh you know since the shooter in uvalde
was stopped by someone who was off duty
with a shotgun that he borrowed from a
barber hey this is case in point how a
good guy with a gun can actually be more
effective than an entire police force
with guns but they should be the only
guys with guns which we'll talk about
because canada is now banning all
handguns this was kind of news to me
growing up there i thought they were
oh really yeah i knew one guy who had a
handgun and it was in a magical basement
closet of mystery that was disassembled
and away from ammo and they were all but
illegal but this is more political
theater we're in canada uh they're going
to ban guns and just to be clear it's
not yes they're going to actually take
your guns away in canada so when you say
it can't happen here in the united
states well it it's happening in canada
and they expressly tell you the reason
that it's happening is because they
don't have a constitution that is their
justification if you look at the supreme
court you look at how they justify and
by the way it's the same justification
that you see here in the united states
when you look at heller versus d the
supreme court case there is no just to
be clear the assault weapons man this is
all political theater it won't do
anything i cannot stress this enough
you need to understand that the only
legal argument once it gets to the court
on the second amendment and if you look
at the dissenting opinions on heller
versus dc it was that you
a private citizen have no right to
firearms whatsoever you can't take it to
the top court and say oh it's about a
trigger guard oh it's about it's about
the shape of the stock no nope it's
either you the private citizen
under the current interpretation of the
second amendment have the right to own
firearms or you don't and canada says we
don't have a second amendment you don't
and the left in this country says we
don't like the second amendment you
don't so let's be really clear about the
goal here let's not be murky on the rule
book now as we discussed this and it's a
sensitive topic we don't know if we will
be on youtube uh for much longer so um
you can watch us on rumble monday
through thursday 10 a.m eastern
rumble or we have an additional 45
minutes today full hour actually playing
uh bad uh bad movie lines oh no with
white dog i'm really glad the racist
film
nice racism with burl ives i remember
that one it's exactly what you expect
it's a racist dog who's white yep oh wow
yeah sequel was black lab but that was
just inner city gang violence all right
gerald a is here how are you i'm well
i'm well how are you i'm fine my
headphones seem a little i guess that's
because dave probably likes the
headphones a little louder is that me
well you were here in my seat oh
you were no your headphones are fine
he's trying to change his schedule i
heard my seat last week i don't know
electronics yeah do you have that do you
have that big phone amplifier that they
sell on fox news i do do you yeah i just
like strap it to the thing a lot of
silver coins from bill devane and a
rascal scooter exactly i'm bill devane
we know i have self-lubricating
catheters not sure what to do with them
but i have them yeah you know what the
fact that it's self-lubricating is not
my primary concern with the catheter no
no i mean you know slipping a little bit
of astroglide on it really doesn't mean
all that much to me once we've crossed
that milestone now if i need a catheter
i need a handgun yes it's
time to send me home or just a good toe
trigger for the shotgun yeah that's it
one or the other just rube goldberg it
where you don't have a bunch of stuff
that happens because you know if i'm
going to end it due to the catheter
which we all would i want to be
entertaining i assume i'm going to be so
hunched at that point i can just toe
trigger a handgun yeah well that's true
yep you'll develop a mighty hump and you
hear him you know him you love him
quickest wit in the west fastest man on
his feet and uh he'll be with me on tour
light of credit.com tour we have a
couple tickets left it's a few tickets
left in colorado springs and then
colorado springs sorry and then uh we
have a fall tour being announced dave
your watch is right in my eye
the reflection this one can you ditch it
the watch well because it's it's
reflecting right in my eye but it's a
sexy sexy tag here all right tell
everyone about how expensive your watch
is it's very expensive okay uh
let's talk about anything
no it's reflecting right in my eye it's
like you're trying to like you're trying
to morse code me tell me exactly where
can i get by
[Laughter]
put it on your other hand i don't care
where under your wrist like a public
school here i'll set it over here i
don't mean to glimmer at you all right
so uh it's my bling also we're gonna be
talking about top gun saw it we're gonna
give give you a review loved it even
though it was corny and you saw that
intro actually they used some of those
lines of dialogue written as a parody in
the real film but
who knew and also important nancy
pelosi's husband dui not nancy pelosi
she's a teetotaler
so
she's not allowed to drive a car at all
right yeah it's hope exactly she's yeah
that's right she's not a tee totally
she's a totaler she totals many vehicles
that's it so it's just she's not even
allowed to sonic speaker of the house
fine cars no no no no no no no no no no
no
she's more of the slur of the house yes
exactly
uh well with what she would put in her
she's the beaker of the house yes
more of a petri dish okay so before this
there's a little bit of levity here uh
this happened at an aquarium uh an
okinawan aquarium there you go token by
the way he's back hey there's a he's
back from his honeymoon there's the face
of a guy who
doesn't know things yeah
oh good honeymoon oh yeah you're gonna
be able to keep your eyes open
yeah
just said
hey hey hey the marriage bed is
undefiled that's true usually not after
what he did enjoy the downhill yeah
i mean congratulations
that's what i meant
gosh imagine being that house cleaning
like housekeeping no don't turn no black
light
yeah it's just forensic files all of a
sudden we just see his face in the next
48. yeah all right we're not sure
yeah hopefully there's not a murder in
the room tonight they're gonna think
it's you
i'm pretty sure he died there there's
too much yeah
so this happened at an okinawan aquarium
which makes it even more funny um it's
pretty clear the fish and i told you
about this before and was dealing with
some heavy stuff you need a watch for it
it's in the top right of
my top right so yeah top right top right
that fish was pelosi's husband yes it
was
just
oh it's just a nap
do something with that peter
they have feelings too
suck at 60 miles an hour
yeah either that is a really really dumb
fish like all fish or that's a fish with
a really good life insurance policy
doesn't have a one second like memory
span that's it yeah so every second it's
just like why do i hurt what do i hurt
why are parts of me floating away
there's my gill there's my kill
hey a
i've gill a terrible life finding spleno
gosh
the water just kind of changed colors
and you're like oh that's blood
write a song about that randy newman
yeah enjoy it
you're drunk
we'll do some randy newman on my club
because that would just take up the
whole show so that was pelosi's
husband's fish
and uh paul pelosi was arrested on dui
here oh man this weekend gracious
charged sunday uh it was sunday morning
after crashing his 20 21 porsche blowing
higher than a uh .08
and uh i believe if i'm not mistaken we
actually because not all cops have
cameras but sometimes they have
microphones yes i believe we have
exclusive audio of the interaction of
pelosi's husband uh pulled over by the
police officer okay
yeah are you all right sir
i'm fine unfortunately that looks like
the nice porsche you have your gut
wrecked it's really the taxpayers
i'm sorry
uh nothing can you arrest me now
on on what charges my wife is the
speaker of the house
nancy pelosi
yeah she she called and insisted i come
home and
pleasure her oh my god i know you poor
thing i know
so i drank some wine and let jesus take
the wheel
i guess he has some other plans for me
because i'm still alive
i
guess i'll have to give you a
breathalyzer the lord works in
mysterious ways just say you did
i'm wasted
the cold steel of a jail cell would be a
warm mug compared to snuggling that
jagged corpse okay i think i'm reading
you loud and clear sir you are under
arrest for driving under the influence
if i reach for your gun will you kill me
yeah let's just stick with the dui but
i'll let you play with it in the paddy
wagon
that's a shame poor guy
you know
i'm not without empathy for those with
whom i disagree no
and by the way it's good to note
supposedly he was alone it's a good
thing good thing nancy pelosi she wasn't
in the passenger seat she uh she could
have been hurt
yeah i mean what if he would have
crashed into a tree i mean a piece of
wood could have gone right through her
heart yeah like final destination yeah
uh 19 yes is what it was nearly 4 00 a.m
that's
close to daybreak she's she could have
been burnt to ash it's true yeah well
thank god nancy wasn't driving under the
influence or thousands might have been
killed yes yeah that's true you need the
netherlands to have a memorialized
flowers better skeleton it's just it's
just vicodin fossilized vicodin i think
that's what it is that's how they check
the age like well let's grab let's break
the humerus and check the rings of
opiates percocet well i mean i don't
blame paul for driving on an influence
he has to make love to that bag of
broken glass yes yeah there's no way uh
he can still get it up though with that
loud lizard i'm guessing that uh he's
just drinking from you know to numb the
pain of having been in there before like
a like a prisoner of war yeah i'm just
hoping that nancy pelosi isn't
admissible or allowable as a key fact
witness because he'll walk oh i think
you're right yeah this is just one look
at her dead owl face and understands
what he had to do when he go home that
he'd be
sharding an owl pellet it's time served
this man has suffered enough sir
this is what i have at home yeah just go
maybe judge joe brown like i sentence
you
to sex with your wife
by the way his bail was like five grand
it was really yeah he was in it you know
and he and he didn't post it yeah yeah
just stayed there i'll just stay here
overnight no it's funny you don't have
500
no no i'm good yeah or five dollars no
no no just catch him being sodomized in
the prison so this is a county jail he's
like i just want to feel again it's like
this is the best sex i've had in 30
years yes
i had to kill that secretary
i'm more concerned with an 82 year old
driving a porsche yeah i want you
driving the slowest largest car possible
yeah or driving a tesla because i know
it's fast but then we could just take it
over on autopilot
he hopes someone does and pulls it into
a bridge he hits the accelerator it's
like ah i think he meant to go to bob
evans well yeah that's why he has a
porsche though because living isn't the
top thing on his list right exactly he's
like i will see what happens he's just
stealing her benzos getting in a porsche
setting it on high and seeing what he
can do napa has mountains right those
are curvy roads and dark you just
driving straight into the wildfires yeah
if she was in the accident they probably
just needed we need eight guys to get
this purse of pills out of the class
oh my gosh he looks right under the
horizon looks at malibu sees the smoke
and just cranks up hearing
wow
let's just commit all right i don't know
who's saying that song someone you guys
can comment below and let me know but uh
top gun has been uh i mean it uh top gun
went mach 5.
into the box office this weekend nice
time yeah i mean it's okay you can you
know i'm gonna i'm gonna drive my
porsche after yeah uh time for much like
that is what killed siskel and ebert yes
no it was gene charlotte oh that's right
that's right i forgot yeah right right
how about you don't how about thumbs up
bang all right
my club movie review let's do it
[Music]
[Applause]
156 million dollars domestically boom
this weekend
154 million though uh of course was part
of it was the budget in ensuring uh tom
cruise's running
i love it
so uh did really well and i think there
are there are some you know there's
there is a subtext here but first it's
important to just in case you haven't
seen anything here's a little look at
what audiences so i think we have a
teaser
what do we have here yeah here i thought
we were special fellas this here's bag
man hang man whatever what the hell kind
of mission is this
everyone here is the best there is who
the hell are they gonna get to teach us
mitchell
let me be perfectly blunt
you are not my first choice you were
here at the request of admiral kazansky
aka iceman
you all due respect sir i'm not a
teacher
i just want to manage expectations
good morning aviators
this is your captain speaking
and we're off here we go
in three
two
one
now apparently i'm the only one here
who's seen the film yeah uh so thanks
guys but uh i i give it mugs up just so
you know i give this mugs up you
absolutely it is oh there you go it's
worth seeing uh of course this corneal
get into a couple but it's worth seeing
alone right two mugs up or mugs up well
because yeah usually well if they had
mugs so i'll give it two mugs up yeah
okay here we go if it was a standalone
film it'd be like a seven out of ten
maybe a six and a half okay but because
of the homage to the original and they
did it very well while honoring the
original that's good while also adding
something fresh it kind of sets a good
blueprint for how to do this this kind
of not a reboot sequel kind of a reboot
because sometimes you'll have people
where it's just a complete retread
you're like that's lazy and then you'll
have some people who go we're gonna go
dark and gritty and change everything
and they you know piss off the fan base
this was a really good balance of it i
think that you should go and support it
for if if no other reason i don't know
if you remember there was news i think
we covered this the taiwanese japanese
flags they were removed from mavericks
jacket
to please china
chinese financiers as mavericks do he
hasn't played by anyone's rules except
for the chinese maverick however
both flags were back on the jacket for
the theatrical release of them so and uh
there was a chinese backer uh uh tencent
they backed out of financing because of
the celebration of the american military
in this film so uh also john cena uh
drove his porsche into a brick wall
that's a shame upon hearing apologizing
in mandarin the whole way yeah did tom
cruise did not say that taiwan was real
does he not know i'm not entirely sure
they have a flag listen
if we discuss taiwan you're going to
make me upset oh and taiwan hasn't seen
me very upset what are you talking about
well you know what john cena that's what
a movie star looks like
oh see there you go you said taiwan
didn't exist because that's what you
wanted to do isn't it steroid freak i
have no idea i don't know
i'm see fast and the furious 28 yes
that's fast also i'm all natural so look
we often crap on hollywood and
rightfully so but i do i will say this
is a bold move and so this won't be
supported uh in china unlike the fast
when you look at the top grossing films
it's usually usually marvel films lord
of the rings and then yeah the fast and
the furious films well they make so much
money in the chinese market yeah and
they really appease them they do that
very consistently like cutting out black
actors yes
right yeah but they allow the samoans
because you know some polynesian land
bridge i have no idea true exactly uh
but this one went the other way and they
will need to recoup it at american box
offices you know what if you watch this
film look it's corny yes it's
predictable some of the lines that you
saw on that intro that we did a couple
years ago they actually included in the
film but it does show that americans
want to see they want to believe in
america again that would be my campaign
if i were running in 2024 i would say
you know it's time to believe in america
again not make america great again it's
time to believe in this country again
let me just say one thing too
you know we all sort of knew this is one
thing about donald trump having a bull
in a china shop that was valuable is we
all sort of knew theoretically that the
kinds of policies that trump implemented
would work
i don't think any of us knew how quickly
things would turn around yeah and a big
part of that is because of you know
speculators in the market but right away
gas prices went down right away we had
record low unemployment and we also had
higher labor force participation rate we
saw wages go up i don't think we knew
how quickly it turned it would turn
around and so as bad as things look
right now i think we're heading in for a
deeper recession it's going to be bleak
the next couple of years there is a
silver lining we know just how fast that
can change and so there needs to be
someone campaigning say believe in
america again i was in a theater
uh it was about half black people
and they were cheering they're going usa
and they were clapping great they don't
care that tom cruise is whiter than
white if it was denzel i'd be doing the
same thing yeah absolutely people wanted
to see a pro america movie we've been
kind of
brow beaten for so long right look even
if you don't want to go and see this
movie if it's not your cup of tea but
you want to see more movies like this
that do have a pro america message they
don't have a ton of woke stuff or any
that i've heard of in this movie no just
buy a ticket don't even go well jennifer
connelly at 53 she woke me up well
that's what it used to be
that's what summer blockbusters were
though even independence day yeah yeah
and like will smith would you know punch
aliens and not comedians right
[Laughter]
time to change just send him down to the
set of battlefield earth let him have a
field day get it out of his system yeah
more of that please and i will say this
actually happened in the theater well
first off there's a lot in the film like
this no one can do this it's impossible
and i was sitting there going and i'm
not necessarily the best at predicting
films but i was going hmm
they say impossible but dare i say it
with maverick the impossible
is in fact possible yeah i feel like
it's gonna
in fact be very i think it's going to be
possible i think it's gonna happen yeah
i thought you were gonna say you're not
the best at going to the movies with
because you yell at the screen when
things like that happen i do
but i was i was surrounded by black
people so they were fine although i did
this is true true story yeah black woman
farted in the theater now i know how did
i know it was her here's exactly how i
know it was her
i was sitting she uh there's a row back
and it was about four or five a fan i
think a family black people she hit it
on you no
oh damn it was uh a black guy i think
his his wife or his girlfriend and then
i couldn't see the other two because
they were a little bit further away from
me but i would have been none the wiser
if what exactly happened didn't happen
you know you hear kind of a sort of into
the into the seat sure and it wasn't the
seat moving these weren't reclining
seats yeah and so i looked back and if
everyone just played it straight but the
black lady went
i oversold it so i looked she looked at
me and i was right yeah and she went
and moved on she knew and she knew that
i knew but i wasn't gonna rat on her
because i know the culture doesn't
appreciate snitching and because you're
americans yes yes we were more
we were more uh involved with
the success of victory maverick
you were too far away to smell it too so
i mean that's true yeah well
theoretically but you know then
afterwards we had to walk out and we had
to go out i had to go past her that exit
you're walking really fast
[Laughter]
all of a sudden it's the first time you
see me wearing a covered mask yeah just
going really quick i'm going to shame
you without words
oh he got an n95 it was bad
so i do recommend it you guys should go
see it it's if they're they're saying if
this can't save the movie theater that
it's done yeah it sounds like it just
did sounds like it just did it was the
theater i was in it was actually not too
crowded but it was a lot of fun is it
corny sure if you like the original top
gun you should see this unfortunately
val kilmer now looks more like john
voigt than val kilmer but i give it two
mugs up go see top gun you know what you
can comment below if you liked the film
it's been mug club movie minute
[Applause]
that sounds like something fred astaire
would uh yeah yeah i'm just glad vel's
in it yeah for real like
hold on i like that
or is he no he's in it oh yeah good all
right like you you don't play
yeah anyone's rules he's doing a few
more movies too yeah i'm happy for him
well unfortunately now you know what the
cat's out of the bag he
service came from zeta jones oh really
it's just a lot of people how else yeah
i love how they were like admiral
kazansky aka iceman i'm like you don't
need the ak yeah especially
yeah you remember him right his body is
now in fact cold as ice he's i mean he's
in the casket by the way i've been here
since the 80s maverick yeah
he's now
embalming fluid man yeah by the way i
knew a fighter pilot and he's like
there's no way they're nicknames or call
signs would have been that cool there's
right he's like usually it's dirt bag
and [ __ ] pardon me
his son was rooster died yeah i love how
by the way they're like you know miles
teller really got into this role you
know he to play goose you know he really
he really hit the gym like what he hit
the gym to play goose yeah what he grew
a mustache no well then what's funny is
he did hit the gym and so they show
goose playing the piano they show miles
teller playing the piano he's got veins
in his neck he's like
really same he's like great
roid raging
much like uh anthony edwards too the the
mustache just makes him look more like
he's 10 years old yeah i know
like didn't quite get it no
both good actors though but i really
like miles taylor i know it gets a lot
of flack i think it's good you guys
fixed the ejection seat thing right yeah
yeah
not in your plane ah brewster same thing
i can okay good
why would you get into that field yeah
well i don't want to spoil it for you
but uh that also causes some friction
between maverick because him and rooster
have a little bit of history via goose
tell you what it's son of a [ __ ] that
maverick finds a way he's really the
dale jr of flying clothes
and uh hangman is the bubba wallace
[Laughter]
all right we have to engage
there's a news that's your eject and
ejection pole is the news it's gonna
break my neck all right i'm gonna hit it
no you don't want to use it that's fine
but that's what it is
yeah they also don't name the villain in
the movie but they're like they they
show it's a nuclear facility they're
building you know enriching iranian
uranium and like and the iranians would
like to get their hands on this it's
like
okay yeah and if i'm not mistaken
someone can correct me in the chat or
maybe the control room i think iran is
the only country that actually would
still have active f-14s which appear in
the film because you know we gave them
to and by the way all these other
airplanes and apaches we gave to the you
know we gave to the taliban as a as a
party favor yeah yeah so okay let's move
on to something else here too uh justin
trudeau canada this is my home country
look i think this is important because a
lot of americans don't realize how
quickly this can come to you here
how quickly just how quickly you can
lose your rights if you want to see how
quickly look to canada and this is the
country uh to whom leftists are
constantly directing your attention we
could be more like canada if donald
trump wins i'm moving to canada
uh you know i love canada because of
their lacks gun laws that alec baldwin
but he didn't understand that they're
all black gun laws they actually have
very strict gun laws he just like
shooting people yeah they still don't
let you commit murder it's his calling
card so
accidental murder on purpose right
i don't know the legal classification
but he's a dick yeah that's what it is
he just careless murder right so justin
trudeau is back to being uh uh you know
you know a tyrant and uh this time he's
now he's now banning any new ownership
of handguns so we have him here
discussing this is the prime minister of
canada for people who don't follow um
for people who aren't canadian you
probably don't no one really cares but
it does matter here he is discussing the
new ban uh at a press conference we're
introducing legislation to implement a
national freeze
on handgun ownership sorry we screwed up
our mistake uh
we have the actual clip right here we're
introducing legislation to implement a
national
freeze on handgun ownership
what this means is that it will no
longer be possible to buy
sell
transfer or import handguns
anywhere in canada
in other words
we're capping the market for handguns
look how smug how self-satisfied he's
like in other words
no criminals will get their hands on any
of these no
we don't border detroit right
[Laughter]
and it's not a real border it's really
just a tunnel
to a casino so besides ben and we're
going to get to the timeline of uvalde
which i think is really important
because a lot of people have an accurate
timelines but this is relevant to that
because you're seeing how the world is
using it as a springboard for pushing um
i don't want to say anti-gun policies
anti-human rights policies so there you
go besides the banning of all handguns
um it's also going to require
military-style assault weapons to be
turned over via a mandatory
a mandatory buyback confiscation why
don't you just write confiscation let's
be clear that's what it is in australia
let's let's do the math when they say a
mandatory buyback because the left has
sold you on buybacks by the way bernie
sanders elizabeth warren beethoven
talked about a buyback in australia it
was amanda what's a mandatory buyback
it's the government is going to
look
they're not buying back a gun that you
bought from the government so it's not a
buy back right it's just we're taking
your gun and we're going to give you
some money so that uh you know you go
along with it if you don't go along half
the value of it right it's like imminent
domain for your house exactly the same
thing for guns and if you don't
go involuntarily with a mandatory
buyback how do they enforce it by their
guys with guns ah just to be clear their
guys with guns will take your guns
mandatorily now here's the thing they're
also saying assault weapons okay maybe
canada is a little further ahead of the
curve than we are and they have a clear
definition because we don't really know
what that means in the united states oh
here's a problem there's no legal
definition so prime minister blackface
said the government would seek to come
up with one that could not be easily
circumvented by gun makers okay
shouldn't you know that before you try
and press along
that's a fair point also i'm not so much
concerned about uh laws you know
technicalities as it relates to assault
weapons being circumvented by gun makers
i'm more so concerned about you
circumventing people's basic human
rights by creating arbitrary laws like
pistol pistol grip illegal rifle grip
legal just new ways to control people's
god-given right to self-defense and
that's what it is it's your right to
self-defense yeah i wouldn't be
surprised if they never came out with a
definition for that because right now he
said until then we'll have it on a
case-by-case basis where they basically
just get to decide
okay on a case-by-case basis we don't
like that gun we don't like that gun we
don't like that gun sorry we haven't
found one that we do like it's weird
yeah
yeah i remember doing lockdowns though
it worked really well in australia yes
and judging by all the masked people
behind him and him unmasked it's no
prediction of the future no not at all
they also did a pitbull ban uh in in
canada and the uk and look and i
understand there's people he's a
terrible musician
all right
no anyone who plays gasolina after labor
day wearing white pants yeah it's just
not fair no they did a pitbull ban but
then people were losing their white
boxers
because they're like well it looks like
a pit bull so whether you're four or
against a pitbull band you can't just
have it on a case-by-case basis you do
need to have a definition because then
they were taking away bulldogs they were
taking away white boxers they were
taking away american bulldogs which
they are not pit bulls at all they're
bullying breeds but neither is a mastiff
this is something that's important and
so when you do it on a case-by-case
basis and the government is the one who
determines the case that ends up being a
serious problem that's tragic and stupid
yeah yeah but it happened no one has to
put it i didn't even know that happened
yep it's happened in the uk too uh joe
lewis would be illegal in the uk
because it looks because he looks like a
pip yeah there's zero pit in him oh i
know yeah but people seem like he looks
like a big pit that's how stupid it is
and i've had to experience i have to
educate people you know he's not a pit
bull they're not really fighting dogs
they're hunting dogs but the point is
it's a silly country and guess what if
your rights are not inalienable
inalienable meaning that your rights
aren't given to you granted to you by
god even if you're an atheist you should
appreciate
that the constitution says our job is
not to grant rights our job is to
recognize rights and then you can have
george carlin saying rights are made up
man as he speaks freely in the united
states which he wouldn't be allowed to
do in other countries like our friends
who were arrested for being stand-up
comedians now here's something else
there is uh it's important to note
there's no cons no i guess it's not
something else it's based on what it was
discussed there's no constitutional
right to own a firearm in canada right
in 1993 there was a
canadian supreme court
case and it ruled that canadians unlike
americans do not have a constitutional
right to bear arms so to be clear
they're proud of it that's the ball game
and what do they say when they say a
mandatory buyback they are going to take
canadians guns away
they justify it by saying well what are
you going to do we don't have a
constitution now let's go to the united
states or they say well the second
amendment is an absolute we don't need
the constitution
look at the court case heller versus dc
they didn't argue oh bump stock they
didn't argue oh class 3 stamp they said
private citizens you have no right to
own a firearm whatsoever that is
exclusively for the military and cops
that's what canada is doing right now
that's exactly what they want here in
the united states by the way i don't
know if you knew this i mean being from
canada a little bit that they have it to
where you can't fire more than five
rounds without having to reload so the
magazine capacity limit is five rounds
did you know that
sounds like uh token now when they're on
his honeymoon
can you imagine though five rounds there
we go fine a home intruder bang bang i
miss okay i'm trying to hit again bang
bang bang i'm nervous and now okay now
i'm just dead you're failing to
understand the equation the gang bangers
breaking into your house they too only
have five rounds ah yes because they uh
they always play by the rules i thought
actually they said most of their gun
crime in canada was committed by people
who had illegally smuggled the guns in
from the united states yeah
just like you know pennsylvania or the
state of new york actually will blame
other you know blind pennsylvania or
some other stuff
gun laws aren't you know tight enough
yeah exactly indiana blames you know or
illinois blames indiana yeah chicago
blames it wisconsin yeah of course
detroit yeah so what you're saying is we
need but they don't have that gun crime
there in wisconsin and they have it in
chicago but it's indiana's fault but if
you if you play this out canada the
united states mexico and every other
south american country all the way down
to you know wherever has to have the
same gun laws otherwise they can just be
like well they just keep coming in
illegally from you know them i love how
he just ran out of countries to name i
did yeah
i was going to say argentina chile you
know they both go down although chile i
love how that's the only one he
pronounces that way he didn't say
i'll call it chili
peru
do you want to talk about brazil
brasilia yeah how are you going to
pronounce it
montevideo you pronounce spain espana
costa rica costa rica
you got to roll into the domino republic
so um of course by the way trudeau used
this as an opportunity to shame america
and this is one of those things where
people say find common ground he's using
this to shame america we're saying the
same thing only he's like i don't know
isn't america terrible and i'm
reading what he's saying hearing what
he's saying going aren't we better than
canada
so here he is saying we need only look
south of the border to know that if we
do not take action firmly and rapidly it
gets worse and worse and worse and more
difficult to counter yeah of course
because there's nary a gun crime in
canada i don't know if you know this my
hometown montreal we were the pioneers
for school shootings mass shootings now
really is this anecdotal ship but i
experienced this in my lifetime
right at it technique that was 1989 i
believe it was 19 women were killed they
were lined up execution style i think
the guy lost his job of like an
affirmative action thing he was pissed
off or was 14. it was 19 was 14. it was
something somewhere between
14 and 19 women i can't remember how
many were killed how many were injured i
know it was at least 14 were killed
there was a concordia shooting in 1992.
four people were killed that's a major
universe there was dawson college my
friends were there in 2006. i did a show
a stand-up show at dawson the next year
in 2007 one person was killed 19 were
injured because the shooter was not very
capable here's something even scarier to
me when you're not just talking about
mass shootings in nova scotia there was
a man who killed 23 people
on multiple separate occasions and
locations he was just roaming for days
with his gun killing people wow the cops
couldn't get no one could do anything
because no one had guns gosh uh scott
thompson from kids in the hall i was
reading the book about them he was in
involved in a school shooting the kid
who sat behind him shot a bunch of
people those in the 70s in canada wow no
i didn't yeah where was he i think
outside of toronto i think okay i
believe but think of how scary that is
not just one event a shooting and they
get sworn by police but one guy just
roaming around with a gun and he's he
knows he can do this unfettered 23
people killed hey there's something very
similar that happened here in texas
sutherland springs guy shot up a church
ago getting into his car to go to
another church and shoot it up and he
was stopped by stephen williford with an
ar-15 who by the way was on this show
that night this was the first show that
he did because he didn't trust the media
to portray the actual story and guess
what when they talk about mass shootings
they never include sutherland springs
it's one of the most deadly ever no
absolutely and one of the things you saw
there in 2020 that's when that last
shooting happened in nova scotia that's
when they started pushing this gun
legislation in new zealand they did
their mandatory buybacks their mandatory
whatever right after they had a mass
shooting in australia they did their
mandatory buyback right after they had a
mass shooting and i know a number of
liberals out there probably like that's
the appropriate response no no you don't
give up your rights because you're all
the sudden afraid i get it it sucks to
live in a world where you can die where
your kids can die in a senseless act of
violence you fix the problem getting rid
of guns doesn't fix the problem it just
ensures that bad guys are the only ones
that are going to have guns period
that's it and i try to avoid the
abortion and gun control comparison
because i think a lot of people make it
and going to be lazy but i do think
there's an important delineation to make
here that people often miss like oh you
want to ban abortions and it's going to
be then people are going to illegal but
you're saying ban guns no no here's kind
of the subjects i think people miss it's
sort of like the prohibition
and war on drugs you're talking about
something different when we enacted
prohibition you're talking about an
activity in which 90 something percent
of americans engaged and made it illegal
that's going to be a problem because
behaviorally people have already
developed that you know this is a part
of the culture whereas legalizing all
drugs i'm not saying that we shouldn't
legalize all drugs i'm not talking about
the war on drugs i'm saying you're
taking some of the very few
uh well only a few percent of americans
actively engage in
and then saying all right go nuts so
it's different the way that it would
actually affect human behavior in the
country is different the same thing when
people say
okay abortion let's compare it to gun
control what you are saying is if we
outlaw abortion or late term abortion or
any any abortion any capacity what you
are saying is that
law abiding lifetime law-abiding women
ah mass are going to go break the law
and get illegal abortions however if we
ban firearms lifetime serial criminals
are going to start obeying the law the
difference there is you were talking
about in the abortion case women who are
law abiding and you have to make the
leap that all of a sudden they'll break
the law you have to you have to believe
the exact flip of that with gun control
that criminals who've already
continually broken the law and decided
to commit mass murder will obey the law
see that difference it's an important
difference to understand
i was also assuming that somebody with a
handgun is going to do you know
it just doesn't make sense these are the
shotguns not going to kill as many
people it doesn't make sense yeah you
already have laws in canada where you
have to reload you have to have five
round capacity right that's it so you're
telling me that that's not enough now no
new handguns
yeah you kind of have knives with green
handles like it doesn't make sense
exactly well i've never seen gun reform
that makes sense say something that
might make sense yeah how about if an 18
year old twitchy kid comes into your
store maybe you'd look into it harder
yeah and i'm not saying that you have to
and people might get mad at that i don't
care like there's certain things that
you could say that might actually make
sense but instead they leap to the most
ridiculous thing possible well not only
that but even if they try and pass
common sense gun reform what do they say
say oh this is a compromise
it never is though what a compromise is
a give and take right there's never a
give so let's even look at the red flag
laws
that's something where people talk about
okay people who should be flagged people
who your neighbor basically are people
who are concerned uh for your well-being
your mental health they can flag you to
the fbi to the local authorities okay
that's the idea and it sounds to people
it sounds good on its surface of course
we all know how that can be abused but
there's that's or never
right mainly that's a take what's the
give how about this
and i'm not saying that we should do
this
but i've never seen this attached to the
red flag laws and by the way anyone who
abuses the red flag law and falsely
flagged somebody is sentenced to ten
years in a federal penitentiary and find
up to half a million dollars how about
that so it's just a stern of a
punishment to use it frivolously yeah
that would be a give and take i think
you might get more people on board with
it because then it makes it
then it makes it something serious but
when you just say hey red flag laws and
people who are anti-gun anyway have no
skin in the game just like they can
report parents to cps if they don't put
their kid on puberty blockers guess what
it's only a take yeah well it was the
same thing with the no fly list you
remember how many people got put on the
note 5 like it's a fantastic thing and
this person like what yeah because
they're senators run no flag i think
stephen hayes the commentator was on a
no fly list well no it was just like you
had a common name that's what happened
is you were put on a no-fly list right
yeah what's that's the that's the take
what's the give right what's the give
government can only take again because
government doesn't serve to give our
government serves to recognize that's
why we are so different from these other
countries people need to understand that
you don't have the right to free speech
in canada it doesn't exist you don't
have the right to self-defense in canada
look here's the thing this is something
people are not going to want to hear too
before we get into the timeline of
uvalde which is very disturbing and i
will tell you what just
not for the not for
the exact reasons that you may think
though those as well but as more has
come out i've found myself disgusted
with the media i've found myself
disgusted with corrupt police
departments and we've discussed this in
the past you know i don't support all
cops i support good cops
but before we get to that
yeah you know what let's get to that and
then we'll i'll go back to this because
i know we're running late on time okay
do you value shooting all right let's
get to the timeline here a lot of you
may not
no what's your right now comment before
you watch this segment what is your
impression of the validation what do you
believe happened
because i i bet you i will get 20
different recaps here well it's because
we've been given 20. we've been given 20
different different we weren't even
given the right count no we weren't even
given the right account by the way hit
the share button if you can uh sharing
is caring and youtube uh the algorithm
value sharing i guess right now and
likes all that stuff i appreciate it if
you don't do it that's fine consider
joining one club so
let's go back to then okay then what we
were told the texas department of uh
public safety um and the lieutenant
chris oliveira said that police engaged
with the gunman so this is what we even
talked about on this show i said it yeah
you said it you screwed up i know i i
believe he didn't screw it yeah you
screwed up you trusted him
uh said that he engaged with the gunman
as he entered the school and it's just
it by the way it happens to be an
inaccuracy that makes his guys look more
heroic
than the cowards they were
at that point we had local law
enforcement school officers as well as
state troopers who were first on scene
and were able to hear the actual
gunshots inside the classroom they tried
to make entry into the building they
were met with gunfire by the suspect by
the shooter some of those officers were
shot so at that point they began
breaking windows around the school
trying to evacuate children teachers
anybody they could uh trying to get him
out of that building out of that school
okay
you'd think if someone had the correct
information at that point you wouldn't
expect a couple of comics and a smart
guy here in a
in a studio
to have it yeah but you would think the
lieutenant cisco yeah well they said a
resource officer confronted the gunman
as he was going into the school but
didn't engage so how did this guy not
know
yeah well the next day lieutenant
olavera said there well it actually
didn't happen a day later
officers are there the initial officers
they received gunfire
they don't make entry initially because
of the gunfire they're receiving it was
reported
that a school district police officer
confronted
the suspect that was making entry by
your guys
not accurate
he walked in unrestricted
initially oops if one of those balloons
don't pop they might all [ __ ] their
pants
good they were brown but at least they
get to go home that night and look
you're listening and i want to be clear
because i was just pulled over by some
police officers yesterday i wasn't
pulled over they were i was a quick trip
and then uh then they saw me and they're
like knocked away like hey we just you
know just you know we kind of like your
show and stuff and i said do you know
that we're all pissed off with police
right now
i said i'm not a black lives matter guy
i'm not a defund the police but you
understand why we're pissed off i get it
i get it i said you know people saying
that your prime your primary priority is
to go home that night like i said when
they're kids being shot
i said exactly
not when there are children being shot
so this is the problem too before i get
into the exact timeline
down to the second
um this is the problem we discussed this
last where they were saying we want more
lgbtq officers we want more black
officers no no we want more officers of
character but that would require
judgment right this is a society where
we don't judge anybody we accept
everyone's reality as though it is
reality we need officers with character
and i will tell you this if people are
being mowed down in a classroom and you
had every warning an ample time to stop
them
but you weren't ready you didn't have
enough cover fire
i'm sorry that's yes don't take the oath
don't take the oath your priority is not
to go home your priority at that point
is to make sure that those six
seven-year-olds eight-year-olds go home
and there are many many instances here
of the police officers abdicating duty
abandoning their post
and it's not in line with what training
should be i don't know what it is in
this department so police officers not
all cops
but you know what you do need to clean
ranks
as far as the shitty cops and i'm not
talking about cops who just pull over
black you know for driving while black
that's not what this is about this is
about the really the primary duty of a
police officer it's not to give out
speeding tickets when you're hiding
behind an overpass i know you get more
civilian interactions and so you get
your promotions that way no it's about
laying down your life for people who
require protection namely the most
vulnerable among us like
children okay
so let's go through the timeline 11am
shooter posted on facebook that he was
going to shoot his grandmother
and he did
shot her in the face
yeah she went to the neighbor and called
9-1-1
she's a hero tough old broad yes
good for her there's a hero
uh 11 15. he then posted on facebook
that he planned to shoot up the school
hey you know there's an algorithm on
facebook and there's an algorithm on
youtube that if we have a thumbnail with
a gun in it yeah it'll be throttle and
notifications won't go out
if you guys are so advanced how about
screening for i am going to shoot up a
school if you're going to or just
there's no way they didn't see that yeah
just there's no way i am going to shoot
right maybe that ought to pop a flag you
you guys are at warp speed to get us
taken down when we're doing parody you
have to make exceptions for people
reviewing the comedic classic stopper my
mom will shoot yeah somebody made a
video with van halen's music there yes
it get to it sorry so 11 27 uh
there was a video that showed the door
to the school dropped open really
important by the way the door was entry
it was open before all of this started
right
now here's the thing
i understand that sometimes if there's a
break and there was some kind of a
ceremony going on you're not going to
scan everyone's id card and the door is
going to be open
once you hear a crash in shooting
outside however
probably a good idea to close it
yeah
the teacher didn't yet
not a hero just to be clear just to be
clear
grandma hero
teacher
not i know you want us to believe these
are all the true these are all the real
heroes no the real heroes are people who
act heroically and no teaching a zoom
class that's really tired and grading
papers after hours doesn't count
i can see her being panicked though and
relying on a police force yeah i mean
you may have forgotten that she may have
forgotten that she did it she may have
been scared and i think most police by
the way would probably
have done a lot different i'm very
confused by this entire so well i think
it'll clear up with the what's the time
so 11 27 the door is open okay then 11
28 this psychopath crashes the truck uh
near the school i don't have a picture
of the truck crash it looks like a
cartoon crash the wheels go out it looks
like one of those you know like like a
truck that's like a has a personality
like
i'm tired and goes
it doesn't even look real so he crashes
out there looks like toontown teachers
saw the crash went inside called 9-1-1
this is now the second 9-1-1 call
still left the door open that's the
teacher who propped the door open to
begin with drop the door open call 9-1-1
so in other words
we now know this has been posted there
have been 9-1-1 calls that he's going to
go shoot up to school
door is open
okay crash outside
she calls 9-1-1 this teacher or teacher
yeah i think it was a teacher was a
female right because i'm trying to get
make sure that everything everything
correct here because there are people
who came in who weren't in the police
force there were people who weren't
necessarily teaching in that classroom
but everything that i tell you all
references available at
lightworkscript.com this is an important
timeline call 9-1-1 second call to 9-1-1
still leaving the door open now you had
two nearby men they approached a suspect
uh the gun shot shot at them they
weren't injured okay
11 30 am
9-1-1 was called
crash was reported
the name of the teacher is being covered
anonymously in reports probably because
she left the door open so 11 31
police arrive
they don't initially see the gunman
the gunman
was shooting
at the school from behind parked cars in
the parking lot so first off this is
someone who's clearly mentally disturbed
i want to know why did he crash his car
what i mean he was he inebriated and
then he's shooting at the school from
behind a parked car in the parking lot
yeah
and at this point howard there's two 911
calls he's not even in the school he's
shooting at the school
where are you cops
shoot them now
now they're 10 minutes late already yes
it should have been at the crash right
should have been at the crash shouldn't
have to crash the guy gets out oh wait
stephen williford with the sutherland
springs shooting what happened the guy
shot up a church got in his car steven
wilford between i can't remember if it
was getting out of his car
or if it was while he was driving but
between the two shootings that the man
had planned stephen williford shot him
and killed him just a random good guy
with a gun nri certified instructor by
the way now we have 11 33 a.m the gun uh
gunman entered the school through the
door that was left open
fired more than a hundred rounds there's
audio evidence and uh he entered into
one of the rooms it's either one 11 or
112. i don't want to give you the wrong
number right now because we don't know
exactly what it was
um
the earlier reports like we saw they
said that he was met
engaged by a school resource officer
that's not true
okay
so we are now at the point where the man
has threatened on facebook has shot his
grandmother who then called 9-1-1 and
said he is out there he is posted twice
publicly on facebook one of which is
saying i'm going to shoot the school he
has crashed his car there have been
another two 9-1-1 calls placed gotten
out of his car
and shot in the parking lot at the
school and now he has gone into the
school and fired 100 rounds
no one's engaged him yet
you don't know man you don't know how
hard it is to be a cop you know what
you're right but here's the thing
i haven't tasted a [ __ ] stew
i'm willing to bet that it sucks
that's true i've not been a police
officer
i think this is a bad job
so now at 11 35 finally three officers
go through the school same door thank
god problem solved oh wait they briefly
exchanged fire with the shooter two were
greys and then more officers entered the
school afterward
that's four or four more officers by the
way
every single law enforcement official
around the country that talks about
school shootings says you do not assume
that it is a hostage situation you
assume that this person is on a killing
spree and time matters you go in as
quickly as possible so now we've got six
officers
right three and four i think well
nobody's three four two and four but a
killing spree yeah yeah
what were you going oh
it's just this is dangerous
yeah
that's that's that's the job yeah 100
rounds have been fired now not including
the rounds outside you've had three 911
calls at this point so at some point
between the first uh first burst of
shots and the second there was a code
black that was announced in the
cafeteria and reportedly employees
didn't even know what that meant they
said code black they said huh just like
they said hey officers engage what
i'm going to wait
11 37
16 more
rounds 11 43 school broadcast over
facebook that they were in lockdown 11
51 more police arrived great they did
their job
how far into this do we have to get
11 54 parents and police are now
gathered outside the building now here's
the thing
i guess if the police
were more concerned
with engaging the gunman than they were
stopping the parents who were willing to
lay down their lives to save their
children from the gunman instead they
were pepper spraying and restraining
parents trying to get to their kids it's
like a real life mystic river only the
police are completely in the wrong
here's a clip
i think you have that there token owen
yeah clip x trying to pull that yeah
all right
so for people who haven't seen this look
this is why cops can't be the only
people with guns let me tell you why
let me let me put this in a nutshell
those cops
weren't willing to defend those children
with all of their firearms
parents who didn't even have them were
they were willing to lay down their
lives for their kids the cops were not
those parents should have guns
they have the right to defend their
children
and you don't have the right to stop
them
not if you're not doing anything
do we have that clip
here
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
let me ask you this
hopefully we don't get banned for this
because you know hey they talked about
rioting and assaulting officers who did
nothing wrong right with black lives
matter protests if you're a parent
that's your kid in the school
kind of what do you do
i'm going in yeah is there anything that
stops you is there anything that stops
you comment below
comment below does that make you an
extremist
hasn't the cop kind of put themselves in
a situation if they're stopping a parent
that
it's either the kid or discomfort for
the police officer and by discomfort i
mean could be a shove
could be a punch
what would you not use any means
necessary when over a hundred rounds
have been shot and 911 calls have been
made and there are six or seven officers
who are already in that school doing
jack [ __ ]
who cares you're trying to get 50 people
grabbing them like stalin
like it just doesn't
it just doesn't make sense they're
screaming the crying they know there's
kids in there they're stopping parents
that's one cop who's not inside right
yeah
we have to wait for it we have to wait
for swat because we don't have something
to break down the door hey i don't know
if you saw this the school has a lot of
windows
yeah can be broken with a rock also it's
a high school classroom door well they
do have hollow doors in the way that
they wedge themselves you do need
something that would actually break it
wouldn't be easy to break down the door
but that's not the only way in yeah it's
not the only way in and they knew that
it was still ongoing you heard the
appearance
it's still going on he's not dead yet so
now
we're about an hour in
1203 p.m we're about an hour in because
this is an hour from when he said he was
going to shoot his grandma shot his
grandma and started so an hour from
there
and we're a good 20 minutes half hour in
here with the school not even counting
the night before when he was sending out
messages to people right people could
have seen any and that was not that
girl's fault people are going off no no
no no no we're an hour in from him
shooting his grandmother who called
9-1-1 so it's 1203 p.m 19 officers
are inside the school at this point
there were three
by a girls 911 at 1203
12 10
12 13. that's third fourth fifth
recording that multiple people were dead
sing where are the officers
sorry sweetheart they're the only people
allowed to have guns
so don't act like you have the corner on
outrage because students
were killed it is outrageous it's
disgusting it's evil
but it's also evil to say only these
people can have guns who by the way
we've been saying for years are
completely ill-equipped and we've
ensured that they are less equipped
because we've defunded them in many
instances she's saying where are the
cops what is she saying where are the
people with guns to stop this guy with a
gun that's what she's saying that's
fourth and fifth calls
and there are 19 officers in the school
not doing anything
12 11.
an officer announced that the parents uh
sorry to the parents of the students
would be moved to the nearby funeral
home for arena reunification
even though they hadn't been saved yet
yeah i think they had evacuated some
parts like the other wings of the
building right but that's it but in
other words the parents are pissed going
what about my kids right oh that's an
ongoing situation what do you mean by
that we're not doing anything we're
monitoring
12 15
border patrol tactical units began
arriving
12 16 and 12 19 that same student dialed
9-1-1 these are now the sixth and
seventh calls now
why don't you just call the cops why do
you need a gun i understand that a
student girl is not going to have a gun
but this same situation occurs all the
time if you look at police response
times across the united states why don't
you just call the only guys with guns
you mean the guys that you said are
corrupt and just want to shoot black
people which i don't believe is true
because statistically it is untrue but i
do believe that there are
inept bureaucracies as we see with this
police department
1217 the school posted on facebook there
was an active shooter well thank you
thank you for that news alert
shooter began firing again
12 21
possibly at the door we don't know
exactly 12 30.
school announced on facebook that
reunification would actually be at the
high school
they seem really concerned with hey
here's the meeting place like it's at a
theme park we're gonna meet by the uh
we're gonna meet by the big uh the big
drop roller coaster okay guys let's meet
back here hey how about you save the
people who are in a room with a gunman
and by the way i don't want to tell you
how you do your job but you've got
dozens of guys with guns
are they all stupid or are they all
[ __ ]
12 36 pm female student from inside the
classroom called 9-1-1 again
that's the 8th 9-1-1 call
she was told to stay on the line then at
12 43 and at 12 47 she told them send
police
now
12 40 the school posted to facebook
again to change the reunification
location to the civic center well thank
you school thank you real heroes for
making sure that the people who aren't
in an absolute melee know where to go
12 50 the police finally got the
wait for it the key
to unlock the door oh oh hold on a
second our police force there the uvalde
police are so equipped that who'd have
thought the door would need a key
[ __ ] didn't you have a contingency
plan
you're the police force
this you're sworn to serve and protect
and a guy locks the door and that screws
your whole plan right there you should
be the only guys with guns
how many keys are on a janitor's ring i
know that's a lot
especially if it's a cartoon janitor i
know
sorry i don't mean to make like no no
it's okay
insanely stupid that i can't wrap my
head around it and by the way a couple
of things this is not again to be clear
this is not what they're trained to do
not at all this is why we talked about
they wanted to ban chokeholds right
because society says ban chokeholds not
only that but they want to ban officers
like mr kerr that coach ban officers in
oakland so they don't want officers at
schools
which
you know what maybe you guys have a
point if they're all going to be like
this right but uh they don't want
officers at school at schools they don't
want chokeholds they don't want lethal
weapons remember they want them to have
tasers cops like the few fewer of them
should have firearms
yeah and less funding would definitely
get them get better quality officers
right yeah exactly sure makes perfect
sense and we got uh flack for saying
well no you shouldn't ban chokeholds
because that is just again it's a lack
of education it's not understanding the
use of a chokehold and we showed it here
on the show people say oh we need to
what we need to have police officers who
are less equipped to deal with violence
hey you know what how about you send in
the social workers
maybe they have some kind of a universal
key i don't know send in the social
workers to deal with them this is why
you're not looking for lgbtq
or black officers or female officers
you're looking for officers who are
capable of good character and willing to
go in and cause irreparable harm to
someone who needs it
when appropriate
when appropriate that guy shooting up
those kids yeah that's a weak man that's
a weak man
that's a weak man you need a strong man
an officer to go in and help handle that
yep might be outgunned yep might not be
prepared guess what that's what you
signed up for yeah
i follow a couple of special forces guys
on twitter and they were saying that it
is impossible it is physically
impossible for one person to hold a room
that has the windows and has the door
there's no way
there's absolutely no way with even the
most basic training for that person to
be able to withstand some kind of an
onslaught from cops
there's no way how about citizens yeah
how about citizens the door the windows
can be broken with a rock now i'm not
saying that this is the exact strategy
but how about lining how about sneaking
up like a firing squad there he is
shoot until you hear it go click at the
shooter tell the girl who's already on
9-1-1 with the police who aren't doing
anything to inform her fellow classmates
to get down or find cover wherever they
can there could be collateral damage i
understand and that's absolutely
terrible but at this point they will all
be collateral damage unless something is
done
shoot through the window at the shooter
cops can't do it because i gotta wait uh
for my i gotta wait for my superior and
i got away from i don't wanna get
written up for this guess what those
parents were willing to now yeah here's
the thing
they did this wrong even after they just
had performed training only a handful of
weeks before the shooting according to
the new york times the training states
that officers first priority is to move
in and confront the attacker they did
not do that why out of fear the problem
is not guns
the problem is not police
the problem on both sides of this
equation is weak
men
yeah you don't want to die a hero right
well
people who are just concerned with their
own safety rights every single every
single toadie
i was just doing my job that's every
police officer here yeah and it's 19
people yeah it's fine to be concerned
with your own safety you just have to
pick a different job yes if you're that
concerned you have to pick a different
job your job is to run towards gunfire
not away from it yep we'll give you
parents from running towards it to save
their kids
if my kid's in there give me a gun
yeah i'll go in there you can i will go
as as far as my adrenaline will take me
well they would probably be in there in
record time if your kid wasn't wearing
his n95 during the reintroduction to
school well that's true yeah well then
of course that then you should be of
course tasing the parents or if you went
in to have some words with a teacher
because your daughter was sexually
assaulted by a
boy claiming to be a girl in the
restroom they'll tackle you for that so
this is the problem that people see and
again it's not all police officers but
you guys need to clean right this is
where
this is where police officers can say
hey
hey that's not what we do
and if if it is that's not what we're
supposed to do
none of this blue wall of silence and
that doesn't always happen but i was
speaking with some police officers here
this week and they they didn't know they
were going yeah i hear the shooter he
was there for like some something he was
there a while i'm going don't you know
this shouldn't you guys be having
a powerpoint presentation on how to not
be a cop how to not handle an active
shooter situation they should be
teaching you this now
if you're a cop and you don't know
exactly this timeline that i'm i am
laying out right now you're bad at your
job
the only point to mistakes being made in
life is so you can learn from them
so let's also look the ovality training
explicitly stated again just so people
know these are weak cowardly men this
isn't even the training protocol it's
not the training it's not the firearm
it's weak men
training says as first responders we
must recognize that innocent life must
be defended
first responder unwilling to place the
lives of the innocent above their own
safety should consider another career
field well that message must have fallen
on deaf ears also by the way
this is case in point it was an off duty
border patrol you know those evil people
yeah yeah who put people in cages off
duty who heard about it from a woman who
i believe was a teacher in the school
borrowed someone else's gun
was the person who went in and stopped
the shooter now i know what you're
thinking was it one of those militias
people with rent no one
one
non-working police officer
with a borrowed gun
fixed with 19 officers
and a set up perimeter and a digital
compound satellite truck
couldn't do
what do you think you think some random
good guy with a gun is going to stop yep
yeah yep and i think in many instances
they're more effective than police
officers and what is he a hero oh and
he's also what's the word alive yes yes
oh that's odd yeah i wonder if 19 people
could have stayed alive had they gone in
there yeah yeah but 19 people did cops
yuvaldi basically said they wanted
everybody to be trained and ready for an
active shooter situation eight weeks
prior to this incident by the way eight
weeks prior they had training and that
training probably included something
like locking doors and barricading
yourself in classrooms you know the
training didn't include
a couple of people on campus that were
concealed carry permit holders that were
willing to go and get a gun to go and
stop the bad guy because if that had
happened if that had been part of the
protocol this may have ended much much
differently yeah early on that has to be
a part of the training otherwise we're
just playing at this we're not actually
trying to do anything no we could have
banned all guns though and then it could
have just gone on for way longer yeah
yeah
right that's got to be it well there
were other there was a woman who you
know saved her two children were hearing
more reports and stories and there were
other teachers who were clearing other
rooms but in many instances these people
didn't have firearms so they're not able
to do anything other than get the other
people who aren't right in front of the
shooter's destruction destructive path
out of the way but yeah i'm not i'm not
saying that teachers should be forced to
own guns no one is saying that no no but
especially when you look at the the
lgbtq aip experiment that's taking place
where they freak out if they can't tell
their students about who they're
scissoring that weekend i don't want
those people to be forced to own
firearms but i do want people teachers
who want to own firearms or faculty who
want to own firearms who can carry
firearms everywhere else in the country
because they are law-abiding citizens by
the way less likely to commit crimes
than off-duty officers can still carry
permit holders just to be clear
i want them to have access to for
talking about defunding well hold on a
second how about we provide funding so
that they have free training there you
go how about this got got it right here
joe biden you want to give everybody in
america that has student debt ten
thousand dollars off of their student
debt right now how about this how about
we give every single school five
thousand dollars to give to two
individuals to pay them every single
year to have concealed carry and to be
able to go in and stop these situations
yeah training we would i think we would
absolutely fund that we would probably
vote on it today and it would be passed
and be on your destination just to be
clear i'm not even just saying well you
know what the school should not be a
gun-free zone period and anyone should
be no no look how about baby step how
about a compromise right a give and take
how about this i will agree that if
someone has a firearm in a school
whether it's a teacher faculty member
dean principal whatever it is that
unlike the citizen uh you know whose
rights cannot be infringed whatsoever
should be required to take more training
yeah should be required to pass some
kind of a test so that they show you
that they can not only carry a firearm
but have some kind of a standard issue
whether it's a retention holster make
sure that there's a safe where it is
locked in a location have random
checkups to make sure that this person
is responsible and that requires what
what funding not defunding make it
available to people who want to do it
and yes
make
make it so they have to jump through a
few hoops there's a give and take
oh wait no canter is going to be hanging
you're going to bend handguns that'll
solve it and that's what vader or work
wants to do here did you see beta work
changes website three times yeah that's
pretty amazing changes website three
times from not mentioning ar15s to we
want you know a ban on ar-15s too we
want to reduce the number of ar-15s
because he too is a weak man or [ __ ]
whichever term you prefer
that's the problem that we have in this
country we have a problem with weak
people
and we've encouraged weakness
and weakness all around and i'm not
talking about bench pressing okay i'm
talking about weakness of character
what do you what do you think a
generation of people are
where are they going to find strength
and inspiration when you're praising the
real heroes as people who go out there
crying because they can't discuss their
personal sex life for god forbid they
can't do another zoom call for the next
year and half and by the way is this
some can we at least say here that we
told you so that we took what do you
think was going to happen when you
locked down students for a year and a
half
for fear of the parent that wasn't for
the kids we all know that wasn't for the
kids if you look at the if you look at
the cdc data but if you look at how
deadly covet would be for kids that was
never for the kids that was for the
teachers sorry the real heroes that they
may not get sick even after vaccinations
even with masks and plexiglass in place
what did you think was going to happen
when you locked down children
when you eliminated their social
safety net
for a year and a half and by the way i
know i can already hear what you're
about to say no it's not at all the same
as homeschooling because guess what you
can homeschool a kid and then you can
take him to uh anywhere else that isn't
locked down like a desolate wasteland
no you lock students down then you lock
them down from other activities and
interactions and we saw you can go back
to the previous show reference available
a lot of credit.com we saw substance
abuse go up saw suicides go up we saw
mental health issues go up and we said
you are going to have a mental health
epidemic you are going to cause
irreparable damage to these children and
there were many people who were saying
that but none of it mattered because
kovid was the political clout du jour
can can anyone out there honestly that
we didn't see
the destabilizing
happening i know you want to blame guns
and we can talk and plenty of you have
talked about guns but this is something
that we directly said would happen and
experts said would happen here's
something else this is why it's so evil
to rob those parents of the ability to
defend their children and again saying
only police can have guns
rape is illegal
we all agree rape should be illegal this
is not one of those issues up for debate
okay
do we all acknowledge that rapes are
still going to happen
of course we know we can have
more effective policies we can have more
effective policing we can look and see
what is it what is it that we can do
objectively to reduce the number of
rapes but we still have to understand
that rapes will happen
and so then you have to say
what is
the more morally acceptable act at that
point
knowing that there will still be rapists
robbing a woman
of her right to self-defense so she has
to sit there and take it or
understanding that some human beings are
evil at least giving her a fighting
chance at least giving those parents a
fighting chance at least giving that
teacher a fighting chance
in other words even if you banned all
guns which is not going to happen in
this country
you still acknowledge no one likes to
hear this
doesn't mean that we're not empathetic
doesn't mean that we don't care about
the lives lost
can we all acknowledge this is still
going to happen
you can never stop
all evil weak men you never can so then
it comes down
to why did gandhi say of all the british
empire's act of evil robbing a nation of
arms will be its blackest gandhi
you know him for fasting
why did he say that
because it is an act of evil to rob
someone of their right to defend
themselves
the likes of which society
before the last century could never even
comprehend
just because it involved boom boom
sticks doesn't make it any different
humanity since the beginning of time has
been evil
and it's largely been an exercise in how
do we contain
or how do we give
the non-evil a chance to defend
themselves against evil that's a huge
part of humanity that and resources
you're never gonna stop all of it
just like you're never gonna stop all
rapes
you need to give the victims a fighting
chance
especially especially now when we see
statistically empirically and now
anecdotally with the shooting that's
undeniable the reason that the police
officers should not be the only ones
with guns i will repeat it is because
they were not willing to lay down their
lives for those children their parents
were
their parents
have the right to own guns and lay down
their lives for their children all right
we're going to go to mukhla but before
that we are going to uh we're going to
play bad movie lines i think right so we
have a teaser a little bit yeah yeah
we'll lighten the mood this is going to
be fun and there's no way we could play
it on on on youtube we'll play uh a clip
because we're going to do bad movie
lines for one of my favorites white dog
a racist talk
the man who owned it how did he turn him
into a racist dog
it's simple find a black wino who
desperately needs a drink or a black
junkie
do anything for a fix
and then pay them
to beat that dog of yours when he was a
puppy
[Music]
darling the people that made him sick
made him permanently same they should be
put to sleep not the dog that's a white
dog
of course he's a white dog
i don't mean his color
he's going to attack and kill black
people
[Music]
[Applause]
i wanted to put a bullet in that son of
a [ __ ] then why the hell didn't you
because there's still a chance to cure
him cure him he just killed a man there
is no way you can cure that dog so you
finally joined the club a club of
horrified people who raised holy hell
about that disease
[Applause]
it's a little less beethoven a little
more wagner we're gonna go play bad
movie lines youtube piss off
[Music]
you